alright thanks so much for for inviting
me and for letting me talk about some
work that I did with my former students
Rob Pedro and keep doogal don't worry my
talks only 45 minutes long so we'll have
any time for the break okay all right so
we all know that the amount of genomic
data that is available is a huge and
increasing really rapidly and so just
looking at one public database the NIH
sequencing read archive it has over
three pedda basis of publicly available
sequencing data comprising short read
sequent experiments from you know whole
genome sequencing efforts metagenomic
sequencing efforts and many thousands in
fact over 150,000 gene expression
experiments from art using RNA seek and
the goal of or one of the goals of my
group is to develop computational
techniques that enable fast discovery
from data at this scale and in
particular for this talk I want to talk
about these gene expression experiments
and the challenge of estimating gene
expression abundance from RNA seek data
and doing that quickly and accurately
and so the computational problem here is
there in in your sample there exists
some number of copies of various
isoforms of a gene okay so here we each
one of these little blocks represents a
different isoform and their present
insert in particular copy numbers or
abundances and the goal is to estimate
the abundances of each of these
transcripts given samplings of short
reads from these expressed transcripts
so what you observe are these short
reads and what you want to infer are
these purple numbers and that's the gene
expression quantification problem and
the challenge it's a hard problem
because first of all this as I mentioned
the scale of even a single experiment is
large there are hundreds of millions of
reads typically in an experiment finding
the locations of the reeds where this
blue read actually matches a given
transcript has traditionally been slow
and the most sort of interesting
computational challenges are that
alternative splicing creates some
ambiguity about rear where the reeds
came from so in this situation this exon
is present in two different isoforms and
so when we see a red read we don't know
whether it came from this isoform or
this isoform and we would really want is
ISO form level quantification of these
abundances and then finally the sampling
of reeds is not uniform there are
sequence-specific biases and
position-specific biases and other
experimental biases that cause the
sampling not to be strictly uniform and
so the challenge here is to the problem
is in the face of these challenges to
estimate these abundances now in the
past people have argued that simple
counting might be sufficient but for a
long time people have known that these
simple models of just treating a gene as
a union of its exons or the intersection
of the exons that are shared by all
isoforms don't work and they don't work
for many reasons some of which are some
of the most important of which are that
they can't correct for but these simple
models can't correct for positional
biases or insert length distributions
and if you look at only the intersection
of shared exons you don't you may throw
away many many reads and this the fact
that these that these simple models
don't work and more sophisticated
approaches are needed has been known for
a long time and that has led to a huge
number of computational techniques that
try to solve this in furness problem i
mentioned in a more sophisticated way so
one of the earliest was cufflinks by
cold trap know and and in collaboration
with Leo pachter here RSM by boli who is
now here at Berkeley expressed by
Robertson factor who is here at Berkeley
sailfish by one of my students and a
collaborating University of Maryland and
Callisto by Bray at all including lira
Packer was here at Berkeley so and
unfortunately I didn't have a chance to
put the many many other programs and
ideas that have worked on this problem
they're far too many to list on single
slot slide so I sort of bias the
selection towards the ones that
or had some connections Berkeley but
anyway it's a well-recognized difficult
problem and are our first effort in it
was this method sailfish sailfish key
idea was to eliminate the step of read
alignment which as I mentioned was
typically very slow so most of these
other all the previous methods relied on
starting with an alignment of the reeds
to the transcriptome and then using that
alignment as the basis for doing the
inference and this alignment step in
terms of time took a really long time
and what we argued in sailfish was that
you could replace this alignment step
with something much simpler really just
counting k-mers that match the reeds and
the transcriptome and get a similar
accuracy much much quickly more quickly
and what I want to talk about today is
not selfish but our subsequent work on
improving both the speed and accuracy of
sailfish in a method we call salmon at
which you can read about here in a
preprint so as I mentioned what we're
trying to do is solve this inference
problem let me just define that the main
variables we're trying to to infer so in
this in reality we have some
experimental mixture which is a set of
transcripts that exist in some relative
abundances that we don't know and say if
we have six copies of the blue
transcript and it has a particular
length say 100 then the amount of the
number of nucleotides associated with
that blue transcript is 600 nucleotides
and so what we can do is talk about the
percentage of the nucleotides that are
present in the experimental sample and
that's called the nucleotide fraction
that's in this case point three point
six and point one and these are the
quantities we want to infer from these
short reads and you know we can do the
basically the standard thing and write
this inference problem as a maximum
likelihood problem where what we're
trying to do is well let me just tell
you what the likelihood expression is
first so we have the
lity of observing these particular
fragments I'm going to use the word
fragment and reads pretty much
interchangeably these are our
observations given the nucleotide
fractions which we don't know that's
what we're trying to find and the true
read origins which of course we don't
know where the reeds actually came from
but this would this encodes where the
reeds which transcripts the reeds were
sampled from and the transcript
sequences which we do know we assume we
know so we can assume that the reeds are
all generated independently and that
just gets us this product of these
probabilities and then we can split up
the this probability into two parts the
part of selecting whether we sampled
from a particular transcript and that's
dependent on the nucleotide fraction the
probability that if you threw a dart you
hit that transcript times the
probability that you generated this
fragment given that you know you
generated it from that transcript okay
so and then we sum over all the possible
transcripts to make this equal to that
so this is the likelihood model and what
we're trying to do is find the
nucleotide fractions that maximize this
probability and the interesting part of
this or one of the interesting parts of
this is this expression here the
probability of observing this particular
fragment or this particular read given
that we're sampling from this a given a
known transcript and I'm going to talk a
little bit more about this term because
it's one of the advantages of the salmon
software and I'm calling it in this talk
by that probability the bias model in
the preprint I think we call it the
auxiliary model it's called i'm calling
it a bias model because it doesn't
depend on the nucleotide fractions it
only depends on the sequence of this
transcript generating this read okay and
this term can take into account a lot of
features about how likely it is that
this fragment would be would come from
this transcript so for example we can
have a probability of
generating a fragment with this
particular length or insert length for
paired-end reads the probability of the
fragment starting at a particular
position on the transcriptome so this
can take into account position-specific
biases the problem that the fragment
comes a was observed in a given
orientation case you have a stranded RNA
seek protocol the probability that you
see a particular alignment so this can
take into account matches and mismatches
and insertions and deletions so this
bias model encodes this all of the
features or the like features of the
likelihood that do not depend on the
nucleotide fraction and it accounts for
these sample specific parameters and
bias eats and salmon estimates these
this auxiliary model the bias model from
the data for each term and every every
time you you runnin so why is this
bottle bias model important well as I
said I'm calling a bias model but it
really can encode a lot of information
about the origin of a fragment for
example if over time you're observing
the fragments you learn salmon learns a
fragment length distribution and insert
size distribution that looks like this
then you would much prefer you give a
higher likelihood probability to this
location for that fragment than this
location so the bias model can can
provide a lot of information alright so
that's that's the the likelihood model
the next step is the inference procedure
for actually finding the parameters that
maximize that likelihood model and
salmon uses a two phase inference
procedure the first phase is an online
inference procedure where it's the reads
are streaming through the program which
is where the name salmon comes from
because salmon swim upstream and then
this produces a set of initial
abundances and equivalence classes and
some auxiliary information which is then
refined in an offline inference phase
so I'm going to talk a little bit about
each of these two inference procedures
the online inference procedure is based
on stochastic collapse variational
Bayesian inference and it processes the
fragments as they come in batches and at
a high level what it does is compute for
each batch a local estimate of the
nucleotide fractions using the current
bias learned bias models and the current
globally global nucleotide fraction
parameters to allocate the reeds and
then for each batch after it finishes
computing this local estimate it updates
the global estimate to get a new global
estimate by adding in some weighted
version of this local estimate and then
it updates the bias model using the
fragments that it saw in that batch
because you're updating these global
parameters frequently in a traditionally
em algorithm that wasn't streaming you
might run through all of your data
update your global parameters and then
run through all your data update your
global parameters so you only be
updating global parameters once through
an entire pass here because you're
updating your parameters more frequently
actually in practice this converges very
quickly and because you're each batch is
basically independently processed we can
process each one of them in parallel and
we use the compare-and-swap instruction
to do this without a lot of
synchronization between threads so it
gives it's a very paralyzed Abal
algorithm
the other output of the first phase is a
reduced representation of the of the
problem in the form of equivalence
classes of fragments so we grouped
together fragments that whose alignments
indicate that they could have come from
the same set of transcripts so in this
case fragments ones before have
potential origins from transcripts one
and two so they get all put into
equivalence class one and also it the
the other output of this online
procedure phase one is affinities that
encode this biased probabilities sort of
aggregated over all the fragments in
this equivalence class saying how likely
is it that the fragments in this
equivalence class came from this
transcript and the advantage of this
representation is that it's much smaller
than the original problem in the space
of the fragments now you're doing with a
space of transcripts and coolants
classes instead of reeds so for example
the you know in a this is one particular
set of experiments where there were 116
million paired-end reads you end up only
with a hundred thousand equivalence
classes on and so and the nice thing
about these equivalence classes is that
they the number of them grows with the
complexity of the transcriptome not the
size of your read set generally speaking
call yeah within an equivalence class
different reads may still have different
probabilities to be generated from
different transcripts in that yes so how
do you deal with this yes actually
that's an excellent question and the
answer is that the ok the on the online
model we're optimizing the full model
without any collapsing of these
individual probabilities and then in the
offline model we approximate these these
individual probabilities by the average
probability over the fragments in the
empirically this seems to work really
well but it's true that the model might
not be exactly the same
okay so we end up with this much smaller
problem and then we do kind of a very
straightforward offline inference where
don't worry about this equation I just
put up here to have something to point
to the we update the number the number
of reads assigned to each transcript
iteratively by assigning the reeds in an
equivalence class proportional to the
abundance of the current abundance of
the transcript at times the affinity and
you just repeatedly reallocate this
until it converges
okay so that's a model the inference
procedure there's one last missing piece
which is how we end up with these
alignments and the the way salmon does
this is using lightweight alignment
where it replaces the need to get a full
alignment of the reads the transcriptome
like you might get from bwa or bowtie
with instead something that doesn't give
you the full details about the
alignments but can find the locations or
punitive locations of the of the reeds
quickly and the way this works is it
uses maximal exact matches so a maximal
exact match between two sequences is a
subsequence in one and a subsequence in
another that exactly matches so there's
no mismatches or in dells and the can't
be extended on either side okay and a
super maximal exact match is a maximum
at exact match that's not contained in
any other maximum exact match so in this
case a maximum match mm to here is a
super maximal exact match but ma'am one
is not and so what salmon does is and
these maximal exact matches and super
maximum exact matches can be found
really quickly and so what salmon does
is look for chains of these super
maximal exact matches so rather than try
to compute an exact alignment it finds
these maximal exact matches it tries to
chain them together together in allowing
small gaps in between them so we are
looking for a delta consistent chain of
maximal exact matches where this Delta
means that the total differences in
these gap lengths is bounded by Delta
okay and so these chains can be found
quickly and so you get you don't get the
the detail of an exact alignment but you
get a pretty good idea of where the the
read could have come from
alright so moving back around to where I
started the challenges for solving this
problem computationally were that
finding the locations of the reeds were
slow salmon solve this by using
lightweight alignment it the alternative
splicing creates ambiguity about the
reeds where the reeds come from so you
don't know where which which isoform are
read in a shared exon came from so Sam
solve this using this two phase
inference algorithm and the sampling of
the reason is not uniform and so salmon
incorporates this sort of rich bias
model that's learned from from the data
and actually I didn't have a chance to
talk about all of salmon there's a lot
more in the code base that that i
haven't mentioned in fact you can
replace our this expectation
maximization sort of traditional max I
mean the traditional maximum likelihood
objective with a variational bay's
objective you can provide your own
alignments called that's called salmon a
line so if you don't want to use the
lightweight alignments you can provide
your own alignments and this lightweight
alignment idea using the SMS was
actually the first one we implemented
there are several others that are
implemented now so there are several
fast alignment modes not just the one
based on smm and for details on those
you can see the code and the preprint
okay so how well does it do this is
simulated data with RNA seek simulator
called RSM sim and human transcriptome
these is a histogram of correlations the
over replicates the starred ones are
different variations of salmon the
salmon colored one or is the salmon that
I talked about just you can see that
there you know it's doing a good job
recovering the known true abundances in
this case because it's simulated data
and that holds up when you use a
different simulator so here's with the
flexsim and different organisms so this
is Z mas let's see we're getting good
accuracy and under lots of different
measures and so in the interest of time
I won't go through all these different
measures but I guess the one you're
familiar with is the Spearman
correlation but these other ones look at
the absolute relative difference and
then the sort of covariance normalized
by the variance
it's also really accurate when you have
lots of isoforms so if you segregate the
genes by how many isoforms they have you
can see that salmon is doing a good job
your lower is better this is the mean
absolute relative difference so we want
to minimize the difference and Salmons
able to maintain good accuracy even when
they're a large number of isoforms and
lastly I want to mention this particular
experiment which I really have to thank
my love who did the experiments so I
can't take any we can't take any credit
for it but it's an interesting analysis
what they did was take 30 samples of RNA
seek samples all from the same
population and the same cell type but
the difference was 15 came from one
where sequence in one sequencing center
and 15 more sequences another sequencing
center okay and there may be some real
true variation between these samples but
we don't know what it is since their
actual biological samples but you would
expect that that if you looked at the
differential expression be just if you
separate if you treat the consequence
ascender as the condition and you look
at differentiating expression between
the sequencing centers you wouldn't see
a very large amount of differential
expression so if you include a GC bias
term in the differential in in the bias
model of salmon what you get is a
relatively low compared to other tools
number of genes that are differentially
expressed between centers and if you
remove this DC bias term salmon's
numbers start to look like all the other
tools numbers so that sort of indicates
that this is probably closer to the
truth of the real amount of differential
expression between these samples but of
course we don't really know the truth
but it's some evidence that having a
really good bias correction model can in
fact improve your or at least improve
your differential expression call
and lastly salmon is is quite fast it's
actually faster than sailfish whose main
reason for existence was speed but you
know to some extent and sorry i don't
have Callisto's numbers up here but to
some extent all of these things are fast
it now at this point we a few years ago
RNA seek analysis was taking you know 6
10 hours per sample now you know Salmons
taking five minutes per sample and
kalisto's is also very fast so the sort
of speed problem has been largely solved
okay so that's all I really wanted to
say salmon everybody should use it it's
open source it has a vibrant use it user
community it's been downloaded at least
a 1,700 times as of November I don't
know what the latest count is the it's
all available open source and it has a
user group
and so again i really have to
acknowledge rob patra we did most of the
work on salmon heat duggal they did a
lot of the running of the experiments
and working through the math and all of
the funding agencies who supported the
work that's it they all assume that the
reference transcriptome is more or less
so if you spike in just some transcripts
that are not in the country have you
done that and work to us within you mean
spike in to the to the reference
transcriptome transcripts that weren't
weren't there what are the barn a seat
yeah yeah we have not done that that's
an excellent thing to do I mean we are
what we are trying to do now is extend
this to work much better when your
transcript reference transcript is wrong
so that's the main line of future work
we haven't done that particular
experiment but
what you said the GC model helped in the
case of the two sequencing centers were
they using different technologies to do
sequencing that would suggest that GC
thighs so yeah there I'm gonna have to
plead ignorance because i didn't i
didn't do the thing but i think that was
the motivation there was some motivation
behind choosing GC as the separating
finest thing yeah but i don't know what
it is I don't want to talk about other
people's sync with things it's good yeah
since that language alignment is within
a factor of two with exact alignment
right from the previous book a factor or
two in terms of time losing all this
information with we can populate all the
informations information well no so this
is I yeah this is a horrible plot
because I think that this is five
minutes versus 100 in what's with 1600
seconds ACI it's I think it might be log
scale but the the the you don't you lose
that much information when you use the
lightweight alignment